hey guys what's up happy tech tuesday
even though today's wednesday i've got a
really great video for you today because
today we're going to be unboxing the new
ipad air 2.
the first thing i'd like to note is this
actually isn't my ipad because mine
still hasn't shipped yet so ryan let me
borrow his for the unboxing this is the
space gray 64 gig wi-fi edition i got
the silver 128 cell version so mine will
be here whenever it actually gets here i
feel like i'm on some sort of list with
apple they're like if justine is
ordering don't ship until the last
possible moment
let's do this just get a nice
little flame right here
just burn that real nice
oh smells really good i'm gonna be sick
completely necessary i'm quite pumped up
about this so here's the box the first
thing you're gonna notice is this is the
ipad air and this is honestly when i
look at this box this does not entice me
to buy something this looks like
what am i buying am i buying a stick did
i just buy a stick in a box i think i
did another thing i would like to note
is it says ipad air on it i was a little
bit concerned that the wrong one was
ordered but it is in fact the ipad air
2. i really need a table for these
unboxings it's quite unfortunate
oh my god it looks just like a big
iphone oh
look at that everything just pops out
real nicely we've got our standard issue
charging brick we've got our lightning
cable inside
some directions
who really
who really reads those here she is new
ipad air too
nice
little tear
you guys like my pants
there yoshi you can already tell just by
looking at this that they put a new
anti-glare i forget what the percentage
was but it was a large percentage of
glare reduction on the new ipads and
when you look at it it sort of has this
blue purplish little tint to it you can
kind of see it
right there we'll see how that actually
holds up when you're at the beach trying
to read a book on your ipad and then it
overheats because it's so hot outside
but don't worry you'll probably be able
to read your book so you can see we've
got the touch id sensor the new volume
buttons
should look just like the iphone look at
this little tiny baby power button
here's the size comparison to the iphone
6 plus
and the new ipad air it's obviously much
bigger let me see if i can find my other
ipad here's the ipad mini
here's our size comparison to the six
plus mini ipad ipad air
nice little family
of pads
hola so since this isn't mine i'm just
going to quickly set it up that's not
mine you are not mine here it is
initial reaction
it looks really clear it basically is a
very large iphone especially now that
apple is kind of integrating the system
where everything works on every system
with yosemite you can basically take
phone calls from your computer you can
text message from your computer so
essentially apple is really changing the
game as far as cell phones are concerned
although for my ipad i did get the
cellular version so essentially i don't
have a very large
iphone
hello it's kind of hard in the video to
really show you guys the crisp
clear
retina screen just gonna have to take my
word for it oh my god look at this
i'm so used to using my mini ipad so
going back to this it's kind of crazy i
mean this is like
you're really big you can now do time
lapse you can do slow-mo video on the
ipad which is great but it's still not
going to make you look cool taking
photos with an ipad it really no matter
how hard you try
you're not really going to look cool but
you know what
sometimes you just don't care
if i didn't already have the original
ipad mini i probably would have went and
upgraded to the ipad mini 3 because
honestly this is my favorite ipad of all
of the ipads that i've had it is the
perfect size
this i feel like is just a little bit
too big but since the iphone 6 plus is
now completely massive and it's
essentially almost the size of the ipad
mini i felt like i should upgrade to the
new ipad air 2. so i did i'm excited i
can't wait for mine to come in so that i
can actually check it out i know a lot
of you guys are probably gonna be
getting the gold ipad which the ipad now
comes in gold i am not a gold fan i was
such a die hard gold fan before that was
all i wanted and it was my life goal to
get the gold iphone and then i got it i
was like i like it so much i will see
you guys later i hope you guys enjoyed
this unboxing make sure you click like
and i will see you guys in my next video
happy tech tuesday on a wednesday bye
you